we brought a nanny so we could you know
so she could get all dolled up and have
a night out and feel like a woman again
she's been just killing it as a mom for
the past two months and so it's nice to
be able to celebrate tonight together
it's been an amazing year it's gotta be
so fun to see this new side of your wife
husband it really is I mean she's so
amazing with our little boy Ward and
just to watch him grow up you know so
fast every time like I'll go you know
out for a few shows and then come back
and see him he just looks different
every time worth about a month old right
he's finally smiling and it's not gasps
it's real smiles um does he take after
your mommy hard to say yeah like so far
he's really chill so maybe more mom than
it did me have you written any new songs
yet since becoming a dad not yet I mean
I think even kind of going to the next
Lady Antebellum record you know all
three of us now have kids and you know
we're gonna start working on it
throughout the summer in the fall and
and just you know it's arrived from a
different perspective I'm sure you know
that it's gonna bring